mm go and rest bunnies forever and we're
playing some pain a - oh it's a right Oh
what is wrong I'm cool hell yeah you
know you're not yeah
oh I'm sorry I want you to know a little
bit more about who's being cool here oh
no you don't know anything about that
how do you know that I don't know
anything about I give me I know you and
you don't know James fraction now what
how dare it what happened why are we
killing people I thought this is the
point Renee
got it got it got it got it Dawson oh
yeah okay okay let's go guys let's do it
okay so I'm just lighting the game now
okay we're not this is non-negotiable
we're just going you get it in before it
[ __ ] games back in the day when
people try to get all right good night
I'm ready
okay ready I'm picking some colitis I'm
ready get all the money out before the
cops kill us okay
I'm Escobar and I kill probably like a
prostitute
yeah I kill a hostage that's not my
thing
I don't kill hostages these are your
money oh no I'm asked about I don't know
if you heard well why is it hard is that
was a little I could find all right that
gives you how hard thing okay fine
let me guys why don't I have my mask yet
it has a moustache are you sure what
well I rock my moustache way better you
would be robbing a bank
those groan hey no survivors hey oh oh
you see that flower I bet it with your
favorite dirty Ted you know they're
[ __ ] what you've got on losing money
Kent you're the camera guy good it
snatched the [ __ ] right I don't see
any [ __ ] oh I cut them off foot oh
good okay
hi-yah I think the plans right yeah okay
I'll get the ball oh please a hit
I was this bomb it's a drill oh we gotta
kill the police oh wait the most plain
side area
don't worry I got a good job Ken Oh a
jump down King ticket why did I jump
down help their sniping is going very
badly
really we're gonna be in trouble because
the place are gonna be like really
aggressive because you kill civilians hi
adding Ken I told you not to kill them
but you know I just couldn't help myself
it's like the syndicate took over and
just turned out not everybody it's a
film you know my fault
ken this is you on your hands all right
no don't come towards I like the way
you're looking at me yeah don't play
this off on me I'm I didn't run again
you just stand stand by the window
damn why like this like like yo through
the doors
Oh got the shot why does this drill
never finishing it takes bear that
tastes like six minutes Jesus Christ pls
thks chin Chinese [ __ ] there is Mike Ken
what just yes
yeah right right this door come on it's
your mission you've got a mission okay
suicide there's a guy inside it we need
to rescue him oh no oh no save him good
job literally that I'm playing see
foreign EXO it's gonna blow up big-time
uh-huh let's get a boo-boo
oh yeah they're they're charging us now
they're taking out the drill save the
man hey man like oh no I did not damn it
Charlie no oh I think he might be dead
this is your fault honey I'm so sorry
Charlie chicken I died you where the poo
is only two days away retirement as well
I closed doors
anyway ha ha ha ok the drill is almost
done yeah
yeah so well where's my whole pack on
the charge if you saw Wilden once yeah
anything's like two users and it goes
guys oh damn nicely the guys was great
Wow he's facing my nipples oh who did it
look very something that's okay Shadley
you those are my nipples yeah same place
same room today what else here a
helicopter
oh well it's 84 minutes that's me I
guess they're gassing ice yeah we got it
it's open get the gold give me the gold
oh my god I'm gonna buy me a go away go
get baggage and then we go get an
outside and we're done
all right way the gum so slow this
stuff's heavy I know I just kill
everyone
oh those [ __ ] oh that is muscle gasps
whit what oh you Transco warfare through
the window cat I'm scared
Oh me he's gonna think I'm too heavy
come on I got you back all right how do
I pick it all up again cabaret singer yo
Oh me what do you do I got you I got you
ahh what's the matter girl what's the
matter boy yeah we are terrible at this
oh why don't you do was work at
McDonald's god damn it oh my god did we
do it
yeah we're rich we're in Vegas that was
intense
I don't even know what happened I like
the snort some coke on Mondays though
not gonna lie
oh wait how we do that I'm definitely
hanging on with the wrong crowd we're
gonna do this one it my doggies I'm the
one come on dear parents warned me about
wait what if
you know I think what said that wrong
nightclub [ __ ] yes yes it's a party we
are the prostitutes I was hoping for I
don't know what a dentist Randy has to
like inspect you to make sure he likes
Berg yeah because we we don't look wet
this is efficient at all
I just got c4 in my pocket don't me hey
hey can we compile the list oh hey girls
how you doing by the way
oh oh yeah it's a party hey girls who
did it at the party at the dance floor
hands up hand are due to do getting down
already what are you doing Ashley I
don't even have a gun well example with
this how there's my [ __ ] once he took a
line of cocaine I'm running slow mo sit
down I'm so high right now
sit down I'm driving down sit down sit
down
there we go guys guys look using about
this look that's what I would not sit on
the dance floor still take him down
how dare he dies I will cook you some
eggs if it's dancing muster moves some
milk mm-hmm I'm gonna do it
oh hey wait what were you supposed to do
here I forgot fine Akiko I found some
cash so we lose everything
oh he will play some poker come on okay
I'll make the money all right Ellen was
totally worth killing seven civilians
for whoa Hagar Hagar whoa whoa no man
what's up girl
smack at the bottom a gun mm-hmm how do
you smack uh eight Oh smell that smell
oh [ __ ] nice mouse meking it I've been
it's mega dance party down to behind
guys
DJ syndicate good what word
[ __ ] in the club say what what what
what
I know those [ __ ] in the club I seen
you i shaking my booty I'm twerking it
up here and hmm pretty look hey [ __ ]
in the club that one right there you
come up here me here see my guy in
motion come here I will tie you up
uh-huh yeah it's an honor how do I get
it to the DJ I'm in the VIP lounge
others people here Felix Leo Todd up I'm
into that kind of thing you know I know
you are you not to tell me it's public
knowledge by now Kane oh yeah oh yeah
yes I asked it really easy oh my god
there's a bar here health yes oh yeah
I'm some kind of girlie tonight fix me a
buttery nipple yeah I get your position
people and then slippery little B if you
would please just start civilian I'll
give you my slippery nipple oh yeah oh
there we go
now you look like you're gonna blow up
yeah you're always smiling
I'm al I'm here come back your face it's
it's difficult
Hey look you're I'm I'm Justin Bieber
peeing in a bucket
Oh how do you get up there I got the
money I got the money yay do a dance
oh yeah we're dancing on the money
where's the drugs though how's the olive
juice Audrina
let's get a desk going on
can I take some money no we got it on me
well you guys didn't even leave me any
well you other some alcohol I'm getting
drop you got to be the DJ don't [ __ ] you
guys I'm really good the place hey you
have chicken nuggets
yeah dude Wow can you oh don't shoot me
what's down shoot I don't shoot me don't
believe me
don't worry you're fine ken you're fine
you're fine you're fine
if you gotta be amazing I can't do
anything I'm still here there we go
I bet it hey I'm coming guys I'm coming
oh wait guys I've got health look they
caught me yeah they got Ken does sons of
[ __ ] it's your fault I can't actually
do I realize that you're not guilty of
anything about you guys really me well
let's go let's get out there actually
get in the van so we can we'll come back
for you you want it you want a candy
Kenny's not here anymore let's party
you're wearing leather trousers in again
what's up you were wearing leather
trousers you know my fashion sense is
pretty admirable I feel like this will
make a great thumbnail I'm getting great
ideas from this do you want okay thank
you for that we're gonna make mask meet
the cooks awesome loving this already I
don't shoot the guts minx no Lopez cooks
we gangsta people okay we're the
gangsters these are my people
hey what's up dudes it's okay it's cool
dumb where's we mentioned find
ingredients we don't kill the [ __ ]
either killing me
serious oh my God look at this [ __ ] it
has to be prostitutes where are they
I'm so disappointed where are they come
to the front door dude where's [ __ ]
awesome come on hahahaha what is going
on here listen to the guy as I was
resting don't shoot on his nipples
that's very rude you know okay let's get
some muriatic acid okay check out the
buildings outside like the shed and
stuff
three of the different ingredients I
found the muriatic acid you need these
you can carry all three at once you
needs final three a drink or uh I'm
gonna come and help you make meth okay
okay I got the mirror I guess it I just
put that in so you don't put it in again
now put it in I'm so hot I know what I'm
doing I cook my men to toriel to make a
whole myriad ik you just have to listen
to the day basically we don't have any
math the story continues no stop doing
our own they won't gonna call us though
- has like he's crystal blue what we
haven't um vomit green Tom your tits are
so nice I have tits oh they're on the
stairs Oh somebody's come in my face
trick oh this just show look what
happens he'll visit guide of the shield
oh my god nice look I got him how dare
you bring shields to our house
Oh BAM there's so many cynic and don't
do it it's not worth it oh don't don't
but God just walked by this
[ __ ] you yeah Oh make it good
Jack Daniels in this game how they're
coming from the world all right as I
found a box of cornflakes
I'd have totally baked right now [ __ ] I
am kind of [ __ ] ate as I got that
she's so much corn flakes right now yeah
I don't know that sounds so good it's
perfect time to eat some corn flakes
there's always there's no milk ha ha ha
[ __ ] them I were doomed I don't want to
live anymore
upstairs I don't know minx got their
cooking oh sorry
she's a chef oh it's really hot I think
we're not gonna do this now don't worry
see look like I'm spinning oh [ __ ]
they're mini that
there okay send your kid is
automatically attracting them why does
their head fly off that's [ __ ] sick
up down
Oh cover me Oh already big meal first
I'm gonna die first
but but you you have to sugar autonomy
otherwise I don't know cornflakes and
math no weights and math wait another
day I'm sorry believe you're not
actually a math crack addict but do we
all have to do this what and what Matt
you see no one maybe some reason he
isn't giving ethical to man that's me
we should just take the meth and then
kill ourselves that's not the plan
let's do that let's just all do the math
right now here's the bad guy he's doing
it oh oh where is it how do you take him
Athletics we don't with a sniffing map
unstoppable I'm gonna make it a match
you can come ready oh no me guys Oh get
out of here you can't come in no form in
six four seconds left
eight you have to make the three bags
I'm Eddie
oh we have to MIT Wow he shot me with a
shotgun right now across today they took
it huh I got you where am I supposed to
like die no no no no no what do you do
it don't let me die
okay wait you know yeah yes or no
yeah put it yes yes I got you I'll do
this syndicate go inside for your
caustic soda in the thing that says
caustic soda what's happening what what
what's of course oh [ __ ] they're
climbing up the windows so I don't have
any ammo whatsoever
sigh did they now want to cook the meth
instead that's what they wanted all
along
alright yeah good
like I mean what you say oh holy man
well no you're so [ __ ] taking all your
page with me okay so we'll end and cook
meth mission failed we failed miserably
predict Saturday we failed miserably
hahaha at least we got some meth frontal
back eyes it was fun getting high with
you but I think I need to go and
reassess my life now cos we understand
it happens every time anyone just one of
those you'll come back one day you come
back they all do look you Poots [ __ ] you
alright brothers I hope you enjoyed this
episode of payday we had a lot of fun
playing it they were like if you enjoyed
helps out a lot hit subscribe to become
a bro today and I'll see in the next
1,000 rads
love you
neither stack up in toasters